mein name ist luca meine lieben freunde
wir spielen heute die drei jüngsten
simulator spiele
herzlich willkommen auf einem kanal das
hier ist das erste spiel und zwar sind
wir ein staubsauger roboter
ja das war's wir sehen hier überall so
extrem super modellierten müll auf den
boden und über den müssen wir einfach
drüberfahren und dann hakt das spiel
kurz und system gibt es nicht wir können
auch so richtig cool hier unter dem sofa
fahren und hier vorne den müll dann auch
kurz einsammeln genau wir können uns
auch auf der stelle drehen
ja
wir leben
künftig frag mich ehrlich gesagt ob das
spiel auch physics hat also wenn ich
jetzt hier gegen das ding gegen fahre
ich kann einfach durchfahren 2020
freunde was ist hier vorne mit der lampe
kann ich da ja vielleicht sogar gegen ok
kraska nicht durch die wand fahren
da fahre ich auch gegen da fängt das
spiel entspannt an zu ruckeln wir haben
absolut gar keinen turbo mode wir können
nicht springen oder irgendwie musik
wechseln geschweige denn ins menü geben
das ist auch nicht möglich
ich finde die einrichtung von dem typen
auch echt bewundernswert ich weiß hier
besser vorne wirklich ein fenster
darstellen soll
ich glaub leider ja allerdings bewegen
wir uns jetzt mal langsam in richtung
küche da kommen wir auf jeden fall auch
über die kleine bodenschwelle hier rüber
wir haben hier komplett anderes parkett
auf dem boden
oder irre ich mich gerade das ist doch
hier total hell und dass sie aber
wenigstens ist die wandfarbe genauso
beschissen ok das wird jetzt ziemlich
england allerdings sind wir schmal genug
um auch hier durch zu passen da vorne
liegt auch noch müll rum ich frage mich
überhaupt allgemein was das ist das
sieht aus wie ein grauer kaufen einfach
ich finde das sounddesign vom spiel doch
einfach bemerkenswert also wenn ich euch
jetzt einfach mal meine musik hier
ausmache
apa
klar wirklich mega viel mühe gegeben das
hier ist das schlafzimmer der person von
der wir hier das was
wunderschönes gemälde darüber am bett
drei solchen speck diese spiele zu gott
verdammt langweilig so unfassbar
allerdings sind jetzt bat angekommen wir
haben surprise surprise wieder einen
neuen boden am start und zwar ebenso
einen fliesenboden wir haben wir auch
noch der hat auch die dusche
überlegt euch einfach mal wie nice es
wäre wenn der staub in einer normalen
wohnung oder einem normalen haus oder in
den normalen raum sich nicht komplett
überall verteilen würde sondern einfach
so wie hier
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir befinden uns jetzt auch schon im
zweiten der drei simulatoren die ich
heute vorbereitet habe und zwar sisters
oder drinking simulator da geht es darum
was der name schon sagt wir müssen
trinken
das können wir nehmen wir die linke
maustaste gedrückt halten und jetzt die
rechte maustaste dann können wir halt so
da
in diesem wundervoll designten spiel
haben wir ebenfalls keine süßigkeiten
was waren das jetzt und wir haben oben
links eine anzeige die seht ihr gerade
nicht weil da die kämpfer ist aber da
steht halt so da irgendwie 2 prozent von
100 also habe ich nichts mehr drin
walking with the moment heißt das ich
muss einfach meinen trinkaus trinke
nicht ab level 3 erreicht
wahnsinn liebe das spiel ist andy mal
ein spiel in dem ich wirklich gut bin
was ist hier los hier ist auch wieder
ich muss auch wieder trinken oder wie
entspannt ich weiß noch nicht genau was
passiert wenn ich da rein laufe er sagt
einfach einer sauna nämlich auch mal gut
bin ich meine schaut euch das an ich bin
jetzt in level 43 kings oder in space im
welt
red
ich befinde mich im weltraum level 6
drinks oder inside im ok also ich soll
mich angeblich in einem monat
ich okay zum ersten mal haben wir ein
level was ein bisschen krasser designte
wo wir halt so ein bisschen auch jetzt
hier seine solar flasche oder was also
wir befinden uns hier gerade wohl auf
irgendeiner convention als auf
irgendeiner messe und da vorne wir
gleich einen vortrag gehalten über
mathematik so wie es aussieht stochastik
oder was das ist ne taffe late breaking
ist so dabei ein empty pool also wir
trinken jetzt unser getränk an einem
leeren pool
ja wunderschönes auto was die leute da
haben wisst ihr was ich habe vier euro
99 für dieses spiel auf steam bezahlt
[Musik]
ich frag mich einfach nur noch warum das
level 12 machen wir jetzt nicht mehr da
geht es irgendwie um eine gigantische
karotte auf der wir unseren sogar
trinken denn ich würde sagen wir kommen
zum letzten simulator den ich uns heute
raus gesucht habe und was ist ein dinner
date simulator den spielen wir nicht mit
der maus oder so also wir schauen uns
nicht mit der maus irgendwie um oder
keine ahnung was sondern nur mit fünf
verschiedenen tasten und zwar wenn ich
jetzt hier crew drücke oder die uhr an
und wenn ich geh drücke schaut er nach
vorne ja irgendwie unser date ziemlich
einsam
[Musik]
mich verwirrt deswegen wie das der typ
die ganze zeit mit uns redet jalabert
halt darüber dass deswegen die komische
ist dass sein date so spät erst kommen
wir haben jetzt auch noch hier die kerze
dazu bekommen wir uns anschauen können
kein anderer in seinem gesicht die ganze
macht ok go canada life argentinischen
rotwein e mail oh oh jetzt los was jetzt
los ist das ist viel aber es sind jetzt
passiert gehe ist einer aber auch einmal
die da auf einmal und viele beklagen
[Musik]
einfach noch ein bisschen weiter aber
ich glaube wenn das gewitter wird heißt
es irgendwie dass sich irgendwas
verändert in unserem umfeld allerdings
ist glaube ich unser date noch immer
nicht so richtig angekommen in der küche
hat sich auch nichts verändert er mich
jetzt mal b
dennoch nicht wir haben ganz viele neue
knöpfe
okay wir haben jetzt dann scheint hier
eine super sache haben wir überhaupt so
viel falsch machen
erst mal umrühren ja kommen jetzt de du
sollst was essen du vollidiot hh okay
wir haben wieder das pairing gezeigt
bekommen das heißt es ist wieder zeit
für den alkohol meine lieben freunde wir
fühlen uns alkohol herein
der bildschirm wird lila die frage ist
was ich jetzt verändert hat ich glaube
der hauptgang müsste jetzt irgendwie
dasein als wenn wir vorhin suppe
gegessen das heißt jetzt müssen wir
eigentlich irgendwie keiner ahnen steak
oder so auf den teller liegen haben
allerdings haben wir absolut gar nichts
es ist nichts passiert kann ich
irgendwas drücken
wir haben kittel vor uns liegen
interessant er steht auf und nimmt seine
zigaretten
und der hält sich fest einfach die
chance meine tochter ist entscheiden
mega betrunken und schaut an seiner
kühlschrank ich also er hört sich jetzt
nicht so frisch gesund an
wir machen und sie kippen
die krippe ist an
wir rauchen und da regt sich immer noch
auf das sein dass sein date nicht
angekommen dass ich weiß immer noch
nicht ob es dann nicht wirklich michael
war also ein mann oder eine frau weil er
hat gerade gesagt kein politiker ab
jetzt weiter die musik wird ein wenig
dramatisch das fenster also ich weiß
nicht was das ziel dieses spiels herrn
einer von euch heavy rain damals noch
für die ps3 oder sogar dass er glaube
ich raus gekommen oder ps4 sogar ich
weiß es nicht da ging es darum dass das
ganze spiel eigentlich ein kriminal
horrorfilm war
allerdings konnte man selbst ein
bisschen die handlung bestimmen und so
fühle ich mich gerade
ich weiß aber nicht wann das alles jetzt
mal endlich vorbei ist
das telefon klingelt nee die person
klingelt an der tür und wer ist jetzt
gekommen mann oder eine frau ist die
frage der
ist überhaupt jemand gekommen da war
ist der typ extrem betrunken gerade der
mutter jetzt allem festhalten
packt seine kippe in den rotwein
[Musik]
er nimmt sich jetzt seine jacke und war
es immer im moment der bildschirm wird
wieder
[Musik]
ich verstehe nicht was wir hier gerade
spielen ehrlich gesagt
das war ja das waren 3 simulator spieler
die ich heute gespielt haben
doch was hat euch gefallen als das getan
hat las gern einen daumen hoch unter dem
video david nicht dann nicht
[Musik]